I'll get off dinner and thank you very
much professor Shapiro for your warm
production and for welcoming me and
inviting me back to to Yale to deliver
this year's george herbert walker jr
lecture in my remarks this afternoon are
proposed to consider the modern
development of the laws relating to
armed conflict in that concert in that
context what i want to do is to devote
special attention to the to the areas of
universal jurisdiction proportionality
equality and complementarity the
development of the laws of armed
conflict during the past two decades has
been dramatic those laws have an ancient
heritage and they were largely based on
reciprocity the law of armed conflict
simply put was it was really the
embodiment of the idea between warring
nations that if you look after my
civilians and prisoners of war I will
reciprocate and look after yours if you
will treat mine don't complain if we
will treat yours in the modern era where
the enemy may not reciprocate the rights
and benefits of the law of armed
conflict it is a moral authority to be
gained or maintained by complying with
the law of armed conflict that should be
that should be stressed this reciprocity
really has come to came to an end with
the 1949 Geneva Conventions the US
forces for example do not necessarily
follow the law of on conflicts for the
sake of reciprocity but do so for what
such actions may say about the United
States its values and its military since
the end of the 19th century a large an
impressive body of laws have been
designed to restrain armies from
attacking civilians without military
justification at the very heart of those
laws lies the principle of
proportionality in on conflict civilians
are to be protected unless the military
advantages
such that the loss of civilian lies is
proportionate to that advantage and
that's a difficult that's a difficult
issue how do you compare and measure on
the one hand military advantage and on
the other the lives of innocent
civilians children women and men but a
war crime is committed under modern
humanitarian law if civilians are
attacked disproportionately this
proportionality test has become a part
of customary international law and is
not contested by any state the
comparison as I've said it's frequently
a difficult one to make and especially
in the heat of battle during the conduct
of wars and that is why the law but that
is what the law requires in terms of war
a margin of appreciation is given to the
armed forces thus in the absence of
intent or a hard degree of negligence it
is assumed that military action is
proportionate and so comparatively
recent times violations of the laws of
armed conflict could only be committed
by governments they did not attract
criminal sanctions it was really a code
to be to be adhered to and obeyed by
government forces and governments that
changed during the course of the 20th
century and the idea the criminal
liability should accompany serious
violations of the laws of armed conflict
gained currency it was really in the
shadow of the Holocaust that the first
serious attempt was made to hold
political leaders and their military
commanders criminally responsible for
crimes committed by those subject to
their command Winston Churchill famously
believed that those evil leaders and
particularly the Nazi leaders were not
entitled to defend themselves and that
they should be put up against a wall and
summarily executed it was however
promote primarily at the insistence of
the United States and the then secretary
for defence Henry Stimson that the Nazi
leaders were
the opportunity of defending themselves
at Nuremberg that was the birth of
modern humanitarian law by which name
the laws of armed conflict became known
there are a number of important legacies
from Nuremberg perhaps the most
important is the recognition of a new
species of crime called crimes against
humanity the idea was that some crimes
are so egregious so huge and so shocking
to the minds of decent people that they
are regarded as being crimes not against
only the victims or the people of the
country concerned but crimes against all
of humankind and this really was the
birth of universal jurisdiction it
followed that if crimes have an
international character that the courts
of any country representing humankind
have the right if not the obligation to
bring such persons to justice there is
in other words universal jurisdiction
for such crimes until Nuremberg that
jurisdiction was recognized out of
necessity only for piracy the first
appearance of universal jurisdiction in
an international treaty is to be found
in the Geneva Conventions of that year
the most serious violations of the
Geneva Conventions were named grave
breaches the grave breaches of the
Geneva Conventions and those nations
that have recognized and and ratify the
Geneva Conventions have obliged
themselves to investigate and to
prosecute and punish people who are
found guilty of committing crimes
against humanity no matter where
committed there is truly universal
jurisdiction for such crimes and it's
important in this regard to bear in mind
that the geneva conventions are the
first international conventions and thus
far the only international convention
that have been ratified by every single
nation in the world is not a member of
the United Nations that hasn't ratified
the Geneva Conventions and therefore
committed themselves
to police and to prosecute people who
commit these violations this use of
universal jurisdiction was followed in
the apartheid convention of 1973 and the
torture convention of 1984 the apartheid
convention unfortunately in my view was
effectively ignored and there wasn't one
single prosecution under the apartheid
convention had there been it could well
have been that a part 8 in my country
could have come to an end a decade
before he did it was however the torture
convention that that made a difference
and that arose from the very unexpected
arrest of General Pinochet in 1998 in a
London clinic at the request of a
Spanish prosecutor law professors
wouldn't have said that as an
examination hypothetical it was so out
of the ordinary that ahead of former
head of state would be arrested in
England at the request of Spain for
crimes committed in Latin America almost
20 years before but that ushered in a
new and new situation in respects of
suspected war criminals the the fact
that he wasn't transferred to Spain
because of ill health in the view of the
then a British government didn't detract
in any way from the effect of that of
that event provision for universal
jurisdiction has has become much wider
and they've been now 13 international
conventions UN conventions designed to
combat international terrorism dating
back from the 70s and all of those
conventions provide for universal
jurisdiction and they do that in order
to preclude any alleged terrorists from
finding a haven in any particular
country all countries are obliged by the
by these conventions and they've been
widely ratified to to to prosecute
alleged
since the Pinochet affair other domestic
courts other than England have used
universal jurisdiction in pursuing
person suspected of committing
international crimes these include
suspected Bosnian war criminals through
London genocide Aires Argentina
torturers and the former dictator of
Chad Hasan hub ray and most recently and
very controversial II an English judge
issued the warrant of arrest against the
former Israeli Foreign Minister Tzipi
Livni for alleged complicity and war
crimes that might have been committed
during the attack on the Gaza Strip just
over a year ago in short it has become a
great deal more hazardous for those
suspected of committing international
crimes to travel abroad and this is this
is having an effect on all continents
that's the one legacy of Nuremberg a
second important legacy was the
recognition of command responsibility
under which commanders are held
criminally responsible for war crimes
committed under their command and I
would stress commanders not only
military commanders but also Civil Air
civilian political leaders it is
accompanied by the denial of head of
state immunity these developments play a
central role in current prosecution's
against heads of state and former heads
of state and their political and
military leaders in many in it may come
as a surprise to you that it to me when
I read recently in a very well
researched book that between january
nineteen ninety and may of 2008 in
domestic and international court sixty
seven heads of state or former heads of
state and government from 40 hundred
from 40s from 43 nations have been
formally charged or indicted on serious
criminal offences the charges have been
pretty much evenly divided divided
between human rights violations and
corruption crimes and and
come as a surprise that many of these
leaders have been have been prosecuted
for both and the two so often go
together the corruption and the
violation of human rights are now turned
from the developments relating to the
jurisdiction of domestic courts to the
establishment of international criminal
courts after what was seen in the West
as a success of the Nuremberg and Tokyo
trials it was assumed at the end of the
1940s that there would be a permanent
International Criminal Court and one
finds Express reference to that in the
in the in the Genocide Convention to
which I have referred and also in the
apartheid convention of 1973
unfortunately it was the Cold War that
put to sleep for almost half a century
the idea of an international criminal
court it was one of the effects of the
Cold War and it was only revived after
the end of the Cold War mainly at the
behest of the United States under the
leadership in that respect of Madeleine
Albright that the the that in the light
of the events in the Balkans in the
early 90s led the United States to to
encourage together with Western European
support to encourage the Security
Council of the United Nations to
establish the first ever truly
international criminal court the
International Criminal Tribunal for the
former Yugoslavia and that was that that
was done in 1993 and it did so under
powers conferred under Chapter 7 of the
charter of the United Nations that
authorized the Security Council to to
pass peremptory resolutions bonding all
Member States it may do so when it is to
when it has distorted determined that a
particular situation constitutes a
threat to international peace and
security that determination was made in
respect to the former Yugoslavia and the
Security Council decided that it had the
power to set up an international
criminal court
as a tool for peacekeeping it was that
essential link that was made that gave
the Security Council the jurisdiction to
do that it made a direct link between
justice and peace as I've said it's
highly unlikely that that that that
would have happened without the
encouragement of the United States and I
would add it would not have happened if
these events had not taken place in
Europe there was no suggestion of the
Security Council setting up a similar
court for Saddam Hussein when he
committed genocide against the Kurds
there was no suggestion of a similar
tribunal being set up against Pol Pot
when he killed some millions of his own
people in Cambodia it was in Europe and
that led to this dramatic development
and when there was the Rwanda genocide
the President had been set and the the
United Nations Security Council could
hardly refuse a request from an African
country to do what it had done for a
European country but the leaders of
Serbia in respect of the Yugoslavia
tribunal rejected the legality and the
jurisdiction and the morality of the
Yugoslavia tribunal they regarded this
as representing an act of discrimination
against their people this complaint came
to my attention when soon after I took
office is the chief prosecutor of the
Yugoslavia tribunal I decided it was
appropriate and politic for me to pay a
courtesy visit to the three capitals of
the former Yugoslavia Belgrade Zagreb
and Sarajevo and my first meeting was
the birth the Minister of Justice in in
in Belgrade and he expressed his
government's strongest objection to the
tribunal he criticized what he called
the biased role of the United States in
having the security council established
that tribunal he pointed out that the
United Nations had not consider setting
up drive unil zin the other situations
to which I have referred and he referred
to some horrible situations in Africa
and he referred explicity to Pol Pot and
Saddam Hussein he said why was the first
tribunal established to put Serbs on
trial this was he has said unacceptable
and act of discrimination and partiality
of course he had a point the only
response i could make without much
confidence i recall was that if this
tribunal was the first and last
international criminal tribunal he was
absolutely correct and it was
unacceptable it would be treating the
former Yugoslavia exceptionally but I
said if others were to follow then
Serbia had no good reason to complain
because it happened to be the first
little did I know that they would soon
in the next year be a tribunal for
rwanda and little did I know that in a
very few years after that there will be
a permanent international criminal
tribunal and international courts for
Sarah Lyon East Timor and now Lebanon
and Cambodia in more recent years in the
wake of the first situations to come
before the International Criminal Court
other complaints have emerged along
similar lines from some African
countries and the African Union they
point to the fact that the four
situations before the International
Criminal Court are all African situation
and they say why has the world led by
the west and the northern countries set
up a tribunal aimed at at looking only
at war crimes committed in Africa of
course the complaints without merit and
unfair because none of the four
situations were determined by the Court
itself three of them were referred by
heads of states of the African countries
concerned uganda the Central African
Republic and the Democratic Republic of
the Congo and the fourth in respect of
Sudan was referred by the Security
Council of the United Nations that is to
blame the court for having chosen those
four situations is a little unfair but
regardless of the absence of
justification for those complaints
from the government of Serbia the
African Union and some of the members
and some of the members of the AU they
teach an important lesson which I think
should be taken into account in order
for any system of justice whether
domestic or international to have
credibility and to gain acceptance there
has to be both the fact and the
perception that the system is fair and
equal in its application and it hardly
emphasize to an American audience the
importance of equality in the context of
justice the experience of this country
with regard to the abolition of slavery
and the civil rights movement make any
further comments are necessary what
requires our attention is that the
concept of equality is closely related
to human dignity if some people are
treated with greater favor if some are
given greater rights and benefits the
dignity of those denied is infringed and
violate the greater the differentiation
the greater is the invasion of dignity
in any nation all citizens demand quite
rightly to be treated equally it is that
denial of equality and the human dignity
of victims that lies at the root of most
if not all of serious human rights
violations without dehumanizing the
victims such egregious crimes would be
impossible to commit there can be no
wanton killings rapes and torture of
those regarded as equals it is those
crimes that form the main body of
international crimes in modern
humanitarian law modern criminal many of
them are to be found in widely adopted
treaties to which I have referred
earlier and especially the Genocide
Convention the grave breach provisions
of the Geneva Conventions the torture
convention and more recently the
anti-terrorist compare conventions it is
the investigation and prosecution of
those crimes that are that are
attracting the attention of both
international and domestic prosecutors
in more and more countries I have no
doubt that our world would be a better
and more peaceful one if all nations
recognized and applied the norms and
principles contained in the charter of
the United Nations and the Universal
Declaration of Human Rights again our
refer to the key norm of equality it is
a matter for regret I would suggest that
in international affairs inequality
rather than equality is just about the
rule rather than the exception trade
preferences the Select club of nations
that are deemed entitled to possess
nuclear weapons which nations may veto
resolutions of the Security Council and
more important and more important for
present purposes which nations are not
questioned when they violate the
fundamental rights of their people or of
other people there is we must we must
accept one law for powerful nations and
a different law for the week it is
disappointing that the United States the
leading power of the world joins with
other large nations such as Russia and
China in refusing to be judged on the
same basis that Americans have always
held should apply to other nations this
desire by the United States to be
treated on an exceptional basis reached
its height during the administration of
President George W Bush it was perhaps
best exemplified by the approach to the
International Criminal Court in this
regard to somewhat ironic that it was
the United States and especially
Madeleine Albright then permanent
representative to the united nations
that led the efforts that led the
efforts of the Security Council as I've
mentioned to establish the Yugoslavia
and the Rwanda tribunals and it was
primarily at her urging that the
International Criminal Court came about
the signing of the Rome treaty by
President Clinton in December of 1999
right at the end of his his term of
office was almost ceremoniously unsigned
on behalf of president bush by john
bolton he infamously stated that his
communication to the secretary-general
of that unsealing made it the happiest
day of his career the bush
administration took extraordinary steps
to avoid the jurisdiction of the
International Criminal Court it
threatened to veto extensions of the
Mandate of UN peacekeepers in Bosnia and
Herzegovina unless the Security Council
expressly granted immunity to the forces
of those nations that had not ratified
the Rome treaty and the Security Council
had to capitulate it threatened to veto
the reference of the Darfur situation to
the International Criminal Court and
this Nationals of countries that had not
ratified the Rome treaty were not
granted similar immunity and and that
they had no obligation to comply with
orders of the International Criminal
Court there are many other instances of
that kind of conduct including i would
suggest with respect the ridiculous
legislation authorizing the president to
send military forces to rescue any
American citizen who might be brought
before the International Criminal Court
I a provision that that earned the the
name of the hague invasion act and you
can imagine how popular that was in the
netherlands and elsewhere in europe it
should be acknowledged that this
exceptional approach of the United
States is not peculiar to the United
States it is common to the majority of
powerful nations international oversight
is approved for the week but the
powerful are to be exempt from it it is
this failure to lead by example that is
retarding a faster development and more
important the enforcement of
international criminal law by shunning
the International Criminal Court the
United States loses the great
opportunity to influence the development
of the court and international criminal
law in general despite the measures that
were introduced by the Bush
administration the International
Criminal Court is
moving forward with prosecution's and
trial that just begun its second trial
and building upon the growing body of
international criminal law once the
leader of that movement the United
States has relegated itself to the
sidelines as other states march forward
in prosecuting war crimes and serious
violations of international human rights
and we should take into account that the
Internet the international criminal
court now has the the act of support
through ratification of the Rome treaty
of a hundred and ten members of the
United Nations and that includes every
single member of the european union
claims by nations to be exempt from
hitherto well accepted norms of
international law have proliferated
since the attacks of 911 it came as a
shock to many in this country that they
were secret torture memos cruel and
inhuman treatment of prisoners by US
personnel at Abu Ghraib and bagram
prisons and secret extraordinary
rendition of prisoners to countries
where they were likely to be tortured
it's in a similar fashion I would
suggest that the present government of
Israel claims that the international
laws of armed conflict should be changed
to allow disproportionate military
responses in order to attack terrorist
groups this should not be regarded as a
plea by Israel for the right to take
measures and self defense for that is
not seriously denied Israel it should
also not be regarded as a plea for the
right to take military measures against
mirror against members of terror groups
responsible for such attacks it can
logically only be interpreted as a plea
for the right to take measures that are
regarded as unlawful under present laws
of Internet rules of international law
no reason has been profit to support
that claim and i would suggest there is
not one from recent media reports in
israel it would appear that leaders of
the Israel Defense Force have come to
wreak
ignores that the suggested changes to
which they've referred in international
law are not going to happen and clearly
they can't happen without a wide
consensus of the international community
let me return to where I started the law
was relating to on conflict requiring
proportionality with regard to military
action that means that the number of
civilians who stand to be killed or
injured by an attack must be justifiable
having regard to the military advantage
to be gained by the action that's for
instance if there are three or four
terrorists firing rockets from the roof
of the hospital containing hundreds of
patients it would not be justifiable or
lawful under the rules of law as I
understand them to bomb the hospital
complex action taken to take out the
terrorists that will cause the death of
injury of a small number of civilians as
civilian patients may well be justified
depending on the danger calls by the
attacks from the hospital and the and
and and the military advantage in
bringing that to an end the former
bombing the whole complex would be a war
crime the latter would not these are
they've already indicated or difficult
decisions and especially in what has
been aptly called the fog of war that is
why as I mentioned earlier the laws
grants a margin of appreciation in favor
of military commanders who take such
decisions I do not propose this evening
to discuss the findings of the UN
fact-finding mission on Gaza and will
content myself by saying that both
Israel and Commerce were found to have
launched attacks against civilians in
Israel and in Gaza in a manner that
constituted war crimes and possibly
crimes against humanity I would
emphasize only that they were certainly
no denial of Israel's right to defend
its citizens from unlawful attacks
indeed the criticisms of Israel in the
report were based on the lack of
proportionality which assumes a right to
take military action international
allmax the exercise
of that right effective notwithstanding
the requirement of proportionality I
proposed to conclude this examination of
the current state of holding war
criminals accountable with a short
consideration of the modern system
called complementarity this requires
that before the international criminal
court is able to exercise its
jurisdiction over the National of any
country the government of that country
is entitled and has to be given the
opportunity of taking control of the
investigation and if there's evidence to
support it any prosecution of that
person if the government does that in
good faith the international criminal
court simply has no jurisdiction if the
domestic investigation is genuine and
not calculated to avoid the jurisdiction
of the court then as I say the court
loses jurisdiction in that case the
system of complementarity is designed to
ensure that whenever possible suspected
war criminals should be investigated and
tried by the course of the suspects own
nation this is a number of advantages
one is that in order to exercise the
right of complementarity nations are
encouraged to promulgate laws that make
international crimes part of their own
criminal law clearly a country cannot
exercise its right of complementarity if
its courts can't investigate and can't
prosecute the crimes in question and
many of the countries that have that
have ratified the Rome treaty have
changed their laws to incorporate these
international crimes and so enable them
to do their own investigations should
should they become relevant and
necessary another advantage of the
system of complementarity is that
alleged criminals would be tried under
the laws of their own nations and that's
appropriate a third and from the
perspective of the United States
probably the most important advantage is
that Nationals of countries willing and
able to conduct good faith
investigations and prosecutions of their
own national national
preclude the International Criminal
Court from exercising its jurisdiction
over them and it's ironic really because
this system of complementarity really
came about as a result of the the push
from the united states that there should
be that protection to to national
systems over their own nationals over
their own citizens it was in the light
of this system of complementarity that
the UN fact-finding mission on Gaza
recommended that Israel the Palestinian
Authority and from us conduct their own
credible and public investigations into
the allegations contained in the report
the recommendation was supported by both
the State Department and the European
Union comest responded to the effects a
months ago that they were considering
such an investigation but nothing
appears to have manifested itself or
materialized in consequence of that
announcement last week there were calls
from a coalition of leading palestinian
human rights groups for both commerce
and the palestinian authority to launch
such dometic to Launceston mystic
investigations into violations of
international law identified in the Gaza
report and and the Gaza report made
serious findings of human rights and
international law violations both both
in both both perpetrated in the Gaza
Strip and on the west bank on Monday of
this week the Palestinian Authority
announced today that it had set up a
five-member committee to look into the
alleged human rights violations by its
security forces in the West Bank and
those though those violations include
assassinations murder and torture and it
of court according to news reports this
last weekend Israel has completed a
military investigation of alleged war
crimes committed by its forces during
Operation Cast Lead whether this will be
followed by an independent inquiry and
open inquiry is apparently still being
the
vated by the government of Israel in the
last 48 hours conflicting statements
have been made by members of the present
Israeli cabinet it is certainly my hope
that Israel will indeed launch of
credible independent inquiry and let me
say that in no way should this be seen
and it's been billed I think
unfortunately as a rebuttal of the Gaza
report I would have thought that the
Israeli government and the Israeli army
would have regarded it to be their legal
and moral duty to investigate
allegations of a serious nature maid
maid maid in consequence of the war to
regardless as a rebuttal suggests that
there wouldn't be these investigations
but the report of the Gaza Commission
and I don't believe that that reflects
well on the policy of the Israeli
government and military the military
investigating allegations against
themselves behind closed doors hardly
satisfies international norms and
criteria and their conclusions even if
made public would bring no meaningful
justice to the many victims of
operational costs led Israel regards
itself as a democracy and should I will
suggest not complain if it is judged by
the standards expected of democratic
nations that uphold the values of the
rule of law if it takes military action
to defend its citizens from unlawful
attacks it has no excuse for not abiding
by the rules of international law that
its enemy does not do so also affords
have no excuse for its own alleged
unlawful behavior let me conclude by
saying that international law will not
be fully effective unless and until all
nations of the world are prepared to
respect and implement it if there was
Universal ratification of the Rome
treaty if every member of the
international community ratified the
Rome treaty and worked for the
International Criminal Court it would of
course become wholly unnecessary for any
domestic call to exercise universal
jurisdiction and that would be a good
situation I think it's inappropriate
for the mystic or to set themselves up
as international calls and get involved
in situations that have nothing to do
with those countries if there was
universal acceptance of the
International Criminal Court that need
would disappear immediately all alleged
war crimes would be amenable to the
jurisdiction of the International
Criminal Court the future of
international justice depends upon the
International Criminal Court and the
system under which it operates achieving
white credibility that is not likely to
happen without the full support of the
United States of America it's example is
paramount and many of the nation's that
are still outside the tent would I feel
confident follow the example and ratify
the Rome treaty if there was a push in
that direction from this powerful nation
the question that faces the
international community and especially
the United States is whether we will
have a better world in which all war
crimes are credibly and efficiently
investigated and those guilty of war
crimes prosecuted and appropriately
punished if found guilty in other words
withdrawing impunity from war criminals
I cannot believe that we would have a
better and more peaceful world if we
revert to the pre-world War 2 situation
in which war criminals were effectively
beyond the reach of justice if we care
about the victims of war crimes and
their rightful claims for justice the
solution i would suggest is knob vyas
one Thank